thank you
anger is growing on the streets of
obuasi miners have been trapped
underground for more than a week without
food or water confrontations between
locals and security forces are becoming
more frequent
anxious relatives want their loved ones
returned home safely
my three brothers are still trapped
they're not among those who came out
we're still praying and waiting to see
them alive
but many of those who managed to get out
were arrested
police accuse them of mining illegally
it's unclear how many of those who
remain are trapped or whether they are
hiding from the authorities
there's no air underground and so we had
to come close to the entrance so we
could breathe but when we came out the
security arrested us we ran out of food
and water so we were drinking the
chemically polluted water
the standoff has stoked long-standing
grievances in the community many resent
companies like Anglo gold the owner of
the mine they say they've been exploited
it's our land but now Anglo gold has
taken all our lands we have no space to
farm no space to bury our dead the land
is ours and we must survive if they
don't put together a policy to give us
what we deserve we will fight with our
last blood
Anglo gold says it's aware of reports
alleging illegal miners may have been
trapped in its mind
but it says they are free to leave
whenever they want
about 1 million people are employed in
Ghana's mining industry
many operate illegally but with lives on
the line relatives say there must be
compromise and that miners shouldn't be
forced to choose between being trapped
underground or imprisoned on the surface
a copper smelter on me